i am joined by katherine hahn one of my
favorite women in the world and she is
in our la studio and we're about to get
a glimpse into the past present and
maybe even the future because catherine
is gonna read my tarot cards
is it true that you are into tarot cards
i was given a deck which i brought today
because
i know you're interested in a little bit
i mean i can't like lay it all out but
what i could do is
what i like to do is i pick a car like
you pick a card
that just
energetically feels right to you
pick it out and then show it to me or
tell me what it is
it's kind of serious business
oh
yeah
oh i want to cry that kind of makes such
sense really okay hold on
hold on let me let mother get her
glasses on
oh i love it so much
the sun
represents rebirth the emergence of the
butterfly out of the cocoon
it symbolizes consciousness and the
active awakened understanding and
appreciation for life
out of the dark womb of night emerging
from the birth canal or the underground
chamber the sun represents the soul's
appearance in all of its radiance
full mental understanding bursts onto
the horizon of consciousness and one
sees what is with joy and celebration
what oh my goodness
okay i have to say one last thing
one last thing oh this is so positive
it's so beautiful when you get the sun
in a reading you can relax and enjoy
yourself it is going to be a good year
you are ex probably experiencing a great
deal of expansiveness and pleasure your
son is shining celebrate
in some ways you have come out of a dark
space and are now feeling the renewal of
energy and friendship life seems to open
and offer you new directions you feel
yourself to be a part of something
bigger than your individual life and le
yet your individuality is freed up as
well
that makes me so
happy
and i just love you thank you for coming
oh my god thank you thank you for giving
me this great news oh please i cannot
wait
to cheer you on with everything that you
do
for now we're celebrating the shrink
next door which is on apple tv new
episodes coming out every friday and you
will not want to miss the show i think
you're the most amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
you